welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of obi-wan
kenobi episode one so we open on
coruscant and right away we should be
worried because there is only one reason
this series would return here
[Music]
so we all know order 66 happened why do
we need to revisit it again well look
closely at the first young lane we see i
think that might be a young riva future
third sister of the inquisitorius the
inquisitors were mostly former jedi
either ones on the fence with the jedi
orthodoxy and easily flipped or once
captured and tortured into servitude and
we don't see what happens to these
younglings yet but i am willing to bet
one of these kids became riva because
later in this episode she says the jedi
are cowards
they failed you abandoned you remember
obi-wan didn't get to the temple until
it was too late that could be riva's
grudge against him what is it you think
you will gain by capturing him
when i'm old
but in the opening shot one of the high
rises we see is likely 500 republica the
vip residence where currently padme
amidala is residing wondering where
anakin is we glide from the urban sprawl
past lush green hedges a natural
seemingly protective barrier to this
serene young lane training session a
session with no lightsabers leaving
these young liens particularly
defenseless now their jedi master is
credited as minas velti a jedi master we
didn't know about until now either way
rit dipper chow switches to steadicam
when the 500 first clone troopers burst
in showing the chaotic perspective of
the huddling younglings ciao makes it so
harrowing very little cutting the camera
moving like a war photojournalist
constantly veltsy checks back in with
her students and her swan song is just
so beautiful to watch with acrobatic
twirls and fluid movements just not
enough to overcome the constant barrage
of blasts so the young liens are forced
to flee
yeah you could hear palpatine's voice on
the speakers of the temple the pa system
really just one plane of execute old s66
is enough to activate the clone
trooper's inhibitor chips but after we
saw some like rex resist clearly
palpatine wants his voice on repeat now
in the jedi temple so that there are no
defections now i scoured this massacre
looking for anagan nada and grogu grada
but as the fighting jedi are gunned down
as we cut to black you can see two green
green-bladed jedi's remaining fighting
that one on the right even pulls off a
gnarly force push obviously there's way
more clone troopers in there maybe one
of these two were able to get away might
have even been that jedi master who
broke free and managed to get grogu out
of the temple the opening title guard
hides the shape of obi-wan's lightsaber
in the eye all of this blew on screen as
sand a little tease for how obi-wan
actually buried his lightsaber in the
sand onto moz eisley ten years later now
ten years after revenge of the sith is
the year nine bby nine years before the
events of a new hope the inquisitor's
transport ship soars overhead it's
shadow cutting down the street like a
gaping mouth pac-man style
ready to devour all of these townsfolk
the twin prongs of the ship reflect the
twin spires of darth vader's castle on
mustafar also in the trailer is the
shape of their chairs and their fortress
inquisitorius on nerve we meet three of
the inquisitors inquisitors being jedi
hunters created by palpatine and given
to darth vader to command they're all
former jedi or at least force sensitive
and they're led by the grand inquisitor
rupert friend apowen a race that we
actually saw in revenge of the sith on
udapal but his appearance has been toned
down here also toned down from how the
character looks in rebel season one when
he was voiced by jason isaacs but he was
a former jedi guard actually present for
the trial of ahsoka tano when ahsoka was
falsely accused and ended up leading the
jedi order song kang plays the fifth
brother who also shows up in rebels
alongside the seventh sister all of that
taking place about five years after this
mozingram plays a new character reba the
third sister i like how this overhead
shot really emphasizes the grand
inquisitor's red tattoos like daggers
aimed out at everyone also reflecting
the points of that ship his eyes are a
fiery yellow better matching the
character's eyes and rebels he tells the
saloon for brighter in actuality i would
say
the jedi hunt themselves
the grand inquisitor eyes the jedi in
the corner nari benny safdi indicating
that he might know at this point who the
jedi is in the room but he draws it out
because the 2017 darth vader comics by
charles soule show how the grand
inquisitor sees himself as a bit of an
academic this guy was denied access to
the temple archives by jocasta new so
now he takes this opportunity to lecture
the room on jedi orthodoxy as a sickness
jedi cannot help what they are their
compassion leaves a trail the jedi code
is like an itch
he cannot help it we see all the
evidence of a jedi scuffle in this place
from the grand inquisitor's sherlockian
point of view the lightsaber burns on
the wall the bandage on the proprietor's
hand from when the bandits robbed him
now thank you to better help for
sponsoring this video have you been
struggling lately maybe you're having
trouble sleeping or difficulty with a
relationship or just suffering from low
self-esteem if so then today's sponsor
betterhelp wants to help you betterhelp
offers licensed therapists who are
trained to listen and help you message
your therapist in a private online
environment at your convenience kind of
like texting a friend on discord there's
a broad range of expertise and better
helps over 20 000 therapists network
that gives you access to help that may
not be available in your area you just
fill out a questionnaire to help assess
your specific needs and then you get
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours then you schedule secure video and
phone sessions plus you can exchange
unlimited messages and everything you
share is completely confidential you can
request a new therapist at no additional
charge anytime join the two million plus
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with an experienced better
health therapist get ten percent off
your first month at betterhelp.com new
rockstars or click the link in the
description that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash new rock stars for 10 off
your first month but riva subverts a
grand inquisitor's lecture and forces
the jedi's hand showing she was totally
willing to murder that proprietor what
she's after scratch scraps are all we
have left then we should be hunting
bigger prey he is not yours to find we
are past this third system interesting
so the inquisitors now have to be more
nuanced to find these better hidden jedi
but rebo just wants kenobi and by
telling her not yours to find indicates
that the inquisitors were actually told
to leave kenobi for vader on to obi-wan
kenobi now going by ben kenobi his alias
from a new hope he works this gig
harvesting meat from a five-finned
whale-like creature in the dune sea i
like how you can see workers on the
higher levels of the scaffolding
spearing new slits into that carcass now
this is not a pergol this is a new
species on tatooine presumably burrowing
through the loose sand like the crate
dragon does the book of boba fett
repeatedly brought up tattooing's
distant past covered by oceans this
whale could have been an evolved
descendant of that kind of sea life we
get a close-up of his butcher knife this
is the same guy who called blasters so
uncivilized compared to lightsabers in a
bloody knife if you think about it a
step further i think it's just a nice
point of contrast to the major step back
that he takes at the end of this episode
the power droid aka the gank droid says
gonk every time it pays them out
i just love that and then ben greets his
eop this is a camel-like writing animal
that we last saw obi-wan on in revenge
of the sith when he dropped off luke
with owen and baru in his cave home ben
stirs liquid into instant stew evoking
ray's portion bread and the force
awakens the jawa atika says she could
smell obi-wan from anchor head anchor
head being a tattooing town mentioned in
a new hope mara i want you to take that
r2u into anchor head and have its memory
erased and she sells them a toy of a t16
skyhopper this is the same toy that we
see luke playing with in a new hope ben
tries to give this one to luke but owen
throws it back breaking it presumably by
the end of the season luke will get this
one and we will all cry knowing that the
toy luke had with him at the start of a
new hope was a gift for monkey ben tika
says that she has a tribe to feed
echoing the meat worker earlier who said
that he had a family defeat know who
else has a family to feed not ben he
grieves the jedi family he lost when
tikka offers him the scavenge jedi
utility belt just like the one he used
to wear as a jedi knight literally the
same kind of costume piece ewan mcgregor
would probably wear for years of his
life his nightmares form a prequel
highlight reel begins with padme's voice
saying i know there's good in him those
were her dying words in revenge of the
sith and the lava of mustafar and anakin
lowing the lightsaber on him during
their duel there obi-wan screaming you
were my brother anakin i loved you
qui-gon dying in his arms from phantom
menace when he made obi-wan promise to
train anakin anakin's red and blue
lightsaber flashes while fighting dooku
and attack of the clones and again
laughing while diving the speeder on
coruscant then anakin screaming as his
face burned off padme's dying breaths
again yoda sane only pain you will find
which is right before he showed obi-wan
the security tapes of anakin killing
even the younglings more dueling on
mustafar then maul's killing blow to
qui-gon obi-wan having the high ground
you were the chosen one then infant luke
with sounds of a baby crying then
padme giving birth and then jake lloyd
anakin in the naboo starfighter cockpit
and it's interesting to note obi-wan was
not present for a young anakin in that
starfighter in all of those scenes
obi-wan was in the naboo palace fighting
maul at the time so that means obi-wan
isn't just remembering his mind is also
linking with anakin's personal memories
in his present mind the force is
bringing them together when obi-wan
wakes up he calls out master quicker
master
remember revenge of the sith ended with
yoda promising to teach obi-wan how to
commune with qui-gon's force ghost one
who has returned from the netherworld of
the force
your old master
qui-gon
how to commune with him i will teach you
so i am assuming we will see or at least
hear liam neeson cameo at some point
this season ben passes a scurrier these
are the little desert rats that showed
up a lot in the book of fat in the
mandalorian and he looks over the lars
homestead looking just as it did in a
new hope ten-year-old luke skywalker
sneaks away from uncle owen joel
edgerton returning from the prequels and
aunt peru bonnie psa also back brew
wears the same outfit as she does in a
new hope and luke wears her hot racer
goggles just like his daddy nari finds
ben who at first adjusts his voice a
little bit you're making some kind of
mistake my name is ben and when nari
calls his bluff obi-wan finally speaks
in his normal voice
you must leave you'll draw too much
attention it's a subtle distinction but
he definitely tried to change it for my
name is ben obi-wan tells him to bury
his lightsaber in the ground which as we
see later is exactly what he did and
then on to alderaan it's our second time
seeing it live action after a brief
scene in revenge of the sith the girl we
see dressed in binary is not leia it's a
decoy a trick that her mother padme
would also use often swapping places
with her hand made in sabe on naboo
breja organa is played by simone kessel
rebecca jackson mendoza played her in
revenge of the sith and young leia is
played by vivian lira blair who you may
have seen in bird box in addition all
these padme parallels it's so sweet to
see how similar leia has become to her
brother luke both these kids sneak away
from their foster parents they climb the
highest point they can they have droids
as their best friends and they spend all
their days staring at ships in the sky
remember deleted scenes in a new hope
showed luke with his friends staring up
at the space battle and leia now being
so comfortable in these high trees
definitely justifies her smooth
transition when she later lives among
the ewoks leia spots a medical freighter
a pleasure barge which she calls boring
as she will later be bored out of her
mind as jabba's slave on his pleasure
barge a casino ship not bad and then a
tri-wing saying that's a new one and
indeed the tri-wing s91x pegasus is a
new one to lucasfilm designed by doug
chang and his team in 2019 for the rise
of skywalker in collaboration with
porsche leia speculates the pilot is an
aquilian ranger scouting for merson
pirates deep cuts here aquilian rangers
were from george lucas's second draft of
his luke starkiller script a non-jedi
race who carried laser swords and used
the force they actually appeared in the
third draft of the screenplay alongside
the rebels on the ivan iv but were later
sort of dropped from star wars canon
meanwhile merson pirates is a legends
detail from mary jo duffy's 1979 comics
but they also exist in canon as a
separatist group from the 2019
role-playing game i mean she just
dropped so many star wars easter eggs in
like 10 seconds young leia definitely
proved herself the ultimate star wars
nerd her droid lola is awesome down
i like how its rings lift up like mouse
ears queen bray house says it's like
raising a glorag which is a deep cut
beast referenced in an article of the
star wars adventure journal i like how
ben's day repeats beat for beat shot by
shot a cool way of showing the routine
he has to go through but this time it
ends with him clashing with owen we
talked about this when the time comes he
must be trained like you trained his
father ooh burn i mean no seriously he
burned him i love how both you and
mcgregor and joel edgerton are vocally
emulating the actors who originated
these roles alec guinness and phil brown
riva and the fifth brother return and
one woman objects
we're not under the empire
yeah fun fact wikileaks co-host tommy
bechtold actually auditioned for this
part also in the background of the scene
is a cameo by star wars podcaster steel
saunders another guy we ran into here at
star wars celebration the fifth brother
leaves a bounty puck for nari the same
kind of bounty poke that we saw on the
mandalorian owen ends up not giving up
obi-wan but he says didn't do it for you
that's because he did it for luke
because if obi-wan was captured they
would figure out why obi-wan was on the
planet and then come after luke the
organist greet their relatives duke
keough duchess celi and casagnano all of
them sugg after the disaster of the
republic the empire is finally lining
some pockets there are still some issues
that we need to address
slave labor
taxation of the outer world i didn't
come here to end slavery
i came to eat your food
save the bleeding hot for the senate
poor bailor ghana trying to still make
anything good out of his phony role in
the senate but the reality is the empire
bribing noble family members like this
is exactly what kept leaders like ko in
line i mean little good that did them
[Music]
c3po cameos anthony daniels voice
translating one alien language into
another r2d2 actually appears briefly a
little bit later in this episode in the
background both these droids were left
with the organas after revenge of the
sith but only threepio's memory was
wiped what
young leia dresses down her shitty
cousin wise beyond her years she's only
10 here it's just fun to imagine nine
years later she will be carrie fisher in
a new hope leia says she'd rather be
digested by a jacko beast then apologize
jacko beasts are bantasized tundra
beasts known for being force sensitive
bale tells her that he used to want to
chase the pergol those were the
hyperspace whales that led to the
disappearance of ezra bridger and thrawn
in rebels leia gets kidnapped by bandits
led by flee the red hot chili peppers
and an actor in his own right bale and
breha beg obi-wan to help but he refuses
the call it's been 10 years
i'm not who i used to be
and so in the third act of this episode
we see obi-wan completing a third day
following the same exact routine until
it is broken by seeing nori's corpse
strung up on display he comes home and
finds his sensor light but now blinking
red meaning an intruder that intruder
being bale who traveled all the way here
for a personal appeal there is no one i
trust more with my child than you
setting a bale later trusting obi-wan
again with leia in a new hope years ago
you served my father in the clone wars
now he begs you to help him in his
struggle against the empire so ben digs
up his lightsabers both his and anakin's
metaphorically digging up both of these
jedi identities that he had buried the
identities of anakin skywalker and
obi-wan kenobi now amazing now there was
nothing there marking the spot he either
recognized the shape of the dunes or the
shadows at that time of day maybe use
the force to sense them either way
pretty impressive reeva tells the
kidnappers he won't be able to help it
the jedi will hunt himself echoing the
grand inquisitor's wisdom from before
you can always count on a jedi by
forcing their hand to save a life and
the final shot shows obi-wan's
lightsaber back on his hip but my
favorite detail about this remember when
he dug it up for the box it was caked in
dust now it is shiny and polished just
like we saw him do every day cleaning
his butcher knife this man respects his
tools especially when he knows he's
gonna have to use it again soon and like
this tool he too has dusted himself off
to get out of the dirt and onto a new
world such an amazing start in the six
episode series i'm gonna be breaking
down episode two in a separate video
coming tomorrow so be sure to subscribe
to new rockstars follow me on instagram
and twitter at eavos follow new
rockstars and the best way to support
new rockstars is to check out our merch
over at newrockstarsmerch.com including
a new obi-wan kenobi inspired shirt
design looks amazing and when you get
one of these you'll get the added option
to write in a custom shout out that will
appear at the bottom of our obi-wan
kenobi after shows wookie leaks so get
on this best way to support us new
rockstarsmerch.com and i'll see you
tomorrow for my breakdown of episode 2.
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you